[Music]
welcome back to on base live in your
bleach Report app I am your host Mookie
Betts and today we're in beautiful
Seattle
and we have Mr Julio Rodriguez what's
going on brother chilling chilling
excited to be here make sure you uh hold
the mic up when you're talking everybody
want to hear you man you know there was
a there was a tweet that came out
um I seen it and it's and it said
move while you're in Seattle you have to
get Julio so I think this interview
is much anticipated so thank you for
coming on bro no thank you for inviting
me and it's definitely going to be a
cool one man it's going to be a good one
so
your two-time All-Star
2022 Rookie of the Year and you won a
Silver Slugger last year
has it has the big leagues been a dream
come true so far I mean definitely you
know you definitely you definitely know
it comes with struggle it comes through
all that but uh just being here it
definitely is being a dream come true
man like
is everything I dream of and more that's
what I can say we're going to get to
that struggle that struggle part of it
because I think
with this being your second year
if you've learned you've probably
learned a lot and we're going to get
into that but first we're going to play
on base off base you've seen the show so
you know what we're what I'm talking
about
first we're going to start with Dunkin
Donuts is better than Starbucks are you
on base or off base on that
when it comes to coffee or what
yeah we're gonna go with coffee I like
Starbucks better Starbucks
so I
I'm kind of like torn because
Starbucks is good like you know I'm not
a coffee guy I would drink tea
but being in Boston bro Dunkin Donuts is
everywhere when we're in Seattle though
this is the star Star Wars is everywhere
here Starbucks is everywhere too and
I've seen this the some of the original
signs of Starbucks
around here you know I didn't I thought
there was just one you know one uh logo
but there's a bunch of different ones
and like they're on every corner the
first Starbucks is actually by uh
the five Market the marketplace it's
closed it's close by the first ever the
first ever Starbucks yeah man the logo
is different and everything so it's
pretty cool how many to go even though
the line is pretty big though oh no
never mind never mind so when you when
you go
to Starbucks what's your order what do
you get I'm a big uh hot coffee but I
tell you caramel macchiato
I don't know about none of that okay so
you get do you get like two squirts of
caramel on them no I just I mean that's
kind of the name of the coffee that they
got over there but I Like It Hot
normally that's what we're doing right
you don't do no iced coffee
don't drink it like that so I just kind
of grew up with it and then that's in
that how often do you go to Starbucks uh
whenever I can honestly especially on
the road all the time especially being
in Seattle you said it on the road
though
I I go the most whenever I'm whenever I
hear I do all my house or you get the
order and they bring it to the house no
I just put a little coffee in the coffee
machine every morning good for you okay
all right so what about this
you're on Tick Tock right you you enjoy
tick tock
have you what what about you thinking
about the Roman Empire more than once a
week do you know about that the Royal
Marine Park Roman Empire no I don't know
much about that me neither yeah I just
seen it on Tick Tock and and I figured
you know I might as well throw it out
there and ask you know you're what 20 21
20 22 22 years old oh my gosh
so I figured you may have seen it
there's a so evidently there's these
girlfriends or wives or whoever they ask
their
their partner
do you think about the Roman Empire now
if you ask me what the Roman Empire is I
can't really tell you
because it was a long time ago but they
yeah but uh evidently they they say guys
think about it I've never thought about
it you know I mean it is what it is I
figure you may you may know so
what about the next one Roberto
Clemente's number number 21 should be
retired on base or off base on base I'm
on base on that too really really on
base what what do you what all do you
know about Roberto Clemente I mean he
was definitely the first lighting Hall
of Fame
and 3 000 hits 3 000 hairs and
definitely like I feel like for us too
um it was a bridge you know it was it
was a bridge for us like lighting for a
lot in community just like Jacqueline
Robertson was here in the states I feel
like that was our Jackie Robinson so I
feel like he's definitely definitely on
base with retiring his number so you're
so if we start a petition
to get his number retired Julio
Rodriguez is going to be one of the
first names you already here okay so
what about this Seattle deserves the NBA
team definitely too so you're a bit
you're a basketball guy yeah I like
watching some basketball who's your guy
uh I'm a big LeBron James guy but if we
were to go with mentality and things
like that I feel like the things that I
that I ran and seen about Kobe Bryant
that you were able to like yeah I acted
so easily to it so I would I would
definitely uh redo a little bit of
research and like learn about him and I
always like seeing stuff like popping on
my feet and I feel like the impact that
he had like an all across sport all
across like different mentality for
people I feel like that anybody that can
achieve that and definitely like
somebody that I'm gonna look up to yeah
and he he did I mean shoot everybody
looked up to him probably even people
that played while against him were
looking up to him so and that's uh
that's good that you brought that up
because I kind of see that sometimes
when when we're watching you like
it's just that you you keep going over
and over but you're having fun and again
we'll get into all that as we uh learn
who Julio Rodriguez is so
you're going and
this is your second year
and
like I said he won rookie of the year
last year but usually your second year
is when you kind of go through your
slumps and hit your bumps and bruises
and all those type of things how has it
been for you this year uh at the
beginning definitely that was that was a
lot of adjustment you know how it is
like you get to the league you kind of
achieve kind of what you wanted in a way
um but then there is more there is
always more there is always thing to
learn and I feel like for me I feel like
adjusting on and off the field was the
thing because you know I signed my
country in the first year a lot of
things that I need to manage that I
didn't have to manage before so I feel
like uh learning how to balance on and
off the field was like my biggest thing
okay so what have you done what have you
done because it's hard it's hard I mean
you know especially a young kid in the
big leagues you know what what have you
had to do I find the biggest thing that
I had to do was setting my boundaries
bro insteading with with people like
family people with people and like you
know like the people around me you know
regardless like sending my boundaries
and like setting my priorities clear
because even though like people around
you sometimes they don't they don't mean
to hurt you they don't mean to do and uh
bad things to you but at the same time
you need to say your priority is clear
because you have so many more
possibilities and so many things that
you could do now that you gotta like
realize okay this is what I like to do I
can support you guys and every single
thing that I can buy I need to get this
you know was it hard saying was it
really hard saying that it was hard but
at the same time uh they understood you
know they understood like all the things
that I that I that I've done all the
work that I that I put that I put myself
through uh and like they understood what
was the goal was you know how are the
possibilities we have we can do all
these things but at the same time it's
like
we're not done yet right right a lot of
things I wanted to do we're here for a
reason and at the same at the end of the
day like I'm gonna be for you guys at
the end of the day regardless I'm gonna
be for you guys about the same time I
got things that I need to do and I
cannot lock up okay so that's off the
film yeah now on the field
what have you had to do because going in
I remember
even after I won MVP in 18 and coming in
the next year like you have
obviously all the people around are have
high expectations of you but then you
have high expectations of yourself
because you just did it you're just
successful right and then you come in
and things are different you know your
body's different pitching is different
you know they're attacking you different
ways and so how has that been for for
you because I remember it was hard man
it was hard trying to live up to those
expectations but pay attention to what's
going on the field and then you got all
this stuff off the field it's just so
take me through that like how has it
been going through all the changes and
whatnot on the field uh on the field is
definitely it definitely was a lot of
ups and downs especially in the
beginning of the year but I feel like
trusting the work that I put in trusting
like myself and like kind of like going
back to the basics because I feel like
it's easy it's easy for us to forget
that what I really got us here like that
what really like made us successful in
that first year and I feel like kind of
going back to the basics and like
breaking everything and that's where
what allowed me to kind of be back to
produce and like help the team in the
way that I would normally would do it
and it's just that just kind of sticking
to the base again what is that what does
that mean though what is going back to
the basis for Julio Rodriguez for me
just let's say at the end at the end of
the year whenever you're feeling good
like your swim your swing is like on
point like you have done it throughout
the whole year is
it's easy to step on the players take a
big hike and like make it and make
damage with it but in the beginning of
the year maybe you got to focus a little
more on the [__] in the middle or
like maybe taking your knocks on the
other side and like taking your walks
and kind of just playing the game
until you build the opportunity you feel
good to say it like that it's almost
like creating some momentum momentous
little walk turn into a hit and then or
and then a hit turn into now I'm driving
the ball and now it's been you know a
month like August right
and
you were hot right I think I had a good
August but you did as well and so you
let it all build and then take me
through your August like did you realize
okay now I'm hot I gotta ride it or were
you just like you know I'm just playing
the game like what what was it for you
uh honestly I never really think that
I'm how like cool or anything like that
if like you know you put in the work you
do your routine it feels good and you
kind of just go and play the game I feel
like in August it just felt like I was
under control all that you know and
that's what it felt good that I was in
the control of my routine on my time or
like where I needed to be at the right
time so I feel like that's why I was
able to have that that good month
because I just kept consistent on every
single thing that I needed to do and so
for those people out there who probably
ask well why don't you just do that all
the time can you explain why we can't
just do that all the time it just
doesn't happen
like that every single I feel like every
single person on beside every single
player is trying to do that every single
time but sometimes it just doesn't
happen sometimes it's a little things in
the middle that they'll say I lied to
and I'm telling you we want to do one is
good we prepare ourselves we sacrifice
we do all these things because we want
to be good in this sport but sometimes
it's not going to happen it's not our
fault it just that's kind of how the
game pulls me sometimes it's it's you
got Julio out there
running down
and making a diving catching the Gap now
instead of me being one for one with a
double now I'm over one and that kind of
changes your mind everything it changes
it changes everything and now one diving
play could lead to a over 12 where you
die but you miss that now I'm one for
one with a double and I get four hits
that day just because it's a mental
thing so you know uh but like I said
you're August you had that same mind
that confidence you may have seen one or
two land you felt good at the plate you
know and controlled the strike zone you
do a lot of really good things you have
been helping your team get to where you
guys are now in playoffs
again right and so how's that you guys
got a lot of young guys too I mean it's
definitely fun and I feel like you
you've been you've been in the spot I
feel like that is not there is no more
fun based with a playoff baseball you
know other than WBC all right all of
them though we see yeah for sure that's
a different that's different that's a
different you put it you put on a league
yeah it's that's different you know when
when you wear that those color of your
country on your chest is different
that's different but
um but during the season yeah baseball
baseball is fun because there is no
other God to win that ball game right
there to move on regardless everybody's
willing to do whatever it takes to take
that dog so I feel like uh being able to
be in that spot competing this late in
the year and like having the opportunity
to be in there is definitely huge you
know and that's what we're trying to do
do you think that you guys can
I'm trying to think of all the the
experience you have around you have some
some good experience some older guys not
even older guys but some guys that have
been around for a little bit and then
but a lot of you guys are young and
young in playoffs as well and so do you
feel like
a disadvantage is that's the wrong word
but how do you feel like that helps or
hurts you because you don't have a whole
lot of the playoff experience I mean we
definitely we definitely don't have like
a lot of guys for like big playoffs
experience but at the same time you
cannot be like blaming on oh we don't
have experience while the other day we
got to go out there and play ball you
know right and if we start thinking oh
let's say this this team has more older
players on us I feel like at the end of
the day we got to lay everything down on
the field no matter what no matter what
if you have experience or not like we
gotta layer everything out on the field
so I feel that's that's how this thing
feels yeah and and playoffs is even in
the WBC now I will say this even WBC
playoffs in the regular season at the
end of the day it's all the same game
it's basically we're always playing
baseball now the energy is different
different the energy is a uh that that
changes a lot right but the the game is
is always the same and so if you get
some guys in there because I I even get
nervous before playoffs now you know I
still you know I get the butterflies
like all right you know we gotta go
especially you know you know you know
what I'm talking about and so if you
guys get in there and you you know you
see some guys kind of nervous or
whatever it's the same game you know but
they also have to
embrace it as well yeah you got it I
feel like if you if you start trying to
cover the sound of one finger then it's
gonna burn you know and I feel like you
got to like acknowledge that this is a
big moment yep but you just gotta take
it like it is you know it's another game
it's a big game but you gotta like soak
it all in yep all right so you and
you're a 30 30 guy this year
yeah praise God uh how hard is that to
do
I mean it is hard you know I feel like
um
people don't realize how much we run how
much we do how much wear and tear your
body a whole season is so and being a
center fielders too yeah so like being
able to maintain that throughout well
that's cool be able to maintain that
throughout like the whole year is
definitely it's definitely hard and be
able to stay on the field playing every
day so it's hard it's hard to maintain
that and I just you know like I said
like thanks to God to be able to keep me
on the field and be able to do that
because you know and be able to be able
to be part of a selected group that that
data is pretty cool so what do you think
about who uh Cooney now he's what's
crazy he's probably gonna be West 70 40.
70 40.
oh that's ridiculous I just say that
people appreciate that I just hope that
people really appreciate that because
from this side from this point of view
that we know how hard it is to play this
game and how hard it's to stay
consistent that's unbelievable to do
it's on it's almost
it's almost like he's he's just toying
with us like he's playing against he's
playing a game that somebody nobody else
is playing yeah he used to play his game
that's funny you know so maybe one day
you'll do that bro
all right tell me about the Home Run
Derby because uh you know this is your
second time uh your second time doing it
did it Dodger Stadium
and then you did it here in Seattle like
do you just enjoy it are you gonna do it
until you win or what uh I mean I feel
like I'm gonna take a break from it a
little bit okay well I definitely
enjoyed it I definitely enjoyed it and
it's a cool I think personally I think
it's cool Ben you know like I got to do
it over there in the Dodger Stadium
which I gotta say man and when you
dialed me up when you were like running
walking behind the the home plate that
was one of the coolest moments no I
gotta say it man I gotta save because I
remember I I kind of grew up in a way
like watching it we were in Boston and
like when you got traded over here too
uh but that was one of the coolest
moments for real like yeah I'm a memory
and Julio Rodriguez's life yeah I know
that was cool man but it's it's a great
it's a great event you know and be able
also to repeat it and come back to back
and doing Seattle here and like just
kind of feel the energy of all those
fans that were like yeah take me through
that so we were sitting I remember we
were sitting on under under when they
were introducing us and you were last
so we all go up and then
your name Julio Rodriguez and everybody
goes crazy take me through that feeling
like how was that how did that feel man
it just it's fair it felt unbelievable I
never had that feeling before and just
kind of feel the whole energy of the
city just kind of waiting for that
moment like building it up and like
knowing oh he's gonna come last or
whatever like just that whole like
energy that they hide which is different
and once I got to it I was able to step
on that plate and just see I look around
a little bit and I just saw everybody
kind of standing up and like just
getting ready for it I just go tell like
go feel like the energy of like
everybody on that feeling like I felt
that was that's why I was able to do
what yeah 40 homework so tell them about
that how did you hit 40 were you just
like it looked like you just started you
were just swinging like you weren't even
paying attention to where the ball was
going you weren't paying attention to
what was going you're just swinging
energy
like that was to this day that's
probably one of the most impressive
things I've ever seen so just know your
memory and moocs and mooc's uh memory
bank as well so take me through that bro
was it four minutes three minutes or
four minutes I think it was that one was
three three minutes four minutes
somewhere and take me through those
three minutes uh I mean it was it was
crazy you know because first of all I
gotta get props to my my boyfriend that
was throwing BP okay yeah uh he was
money but
man I would just I blacked out just see
your ball hit ball and like I wasn't
trying to do too much I was trying to
stay consistent through it but I could
just hear the Roar of the crowd every
single time that I would like made that
contact in that spot and
it was it was unbelievable it was
unbelievable just like feeling the Roar
of the crowd just kind of like swinging
just putting a good swing after good
swing after it and like I said my man
family he was on it yeah and that's huge
that yeah having a good BP thrower yeah
definitely and like he was just
consistent the whole time and would
definitely say consistent throughout the
whole ride and I remember when I when I
finished I had like 40 the 41 I was like
man I'm I'm done you didn't want to you
yeah
I'm telling you I feel after that round
I was like man
I basically did it for the city
everything I got okay so tell me before
that I think on your on your blog you
had said that ohtani was in the cage he
was in there for a while tell me about
that tell me about that story you don't
have to throw them under the bus you
know whatever but tell me about that
because you needed to get in there and
warm up even though you're only 22. yeah
so it was it was basically I started to
watch it's a video so he was he was
going to start doing his routine and all
that but like that was a time that I had
in my head okay I need to warm up at
this time to be ready for my round and
whenever I saw him in the cage I was
like man this is so tiny right so I
can't I can say anything about the same
time in my head man I got a practice
right so whenever I walked in I looked
and I was like man I'm a little you know
like gotta respect to God and awesome
surely I love you to that but
so he understood it was a nice guy but
he was cool he was cool about it all
right so
um and you're a young guy and
I think we all have been trying to kind
of
change the culture of baseball
we're all doing any kind of our
different ways right and celebrations
have been you know kind of a
a good thing and a Bad Thing depending
on which side of the fence you are
depending on if you're a part of the
older generation or the other younger
generation
and I'm kind of right in the middle I'm
right in the middle so
what do you how do you feel about
celebrations and and how they affect the
team I mean I'm all in to celebrate you
know all my little celebrating I feel
like we know how hard this game is and
were you able to do something good in
this in the toughest sport in the
history of the universe say like that
man you got to be able to celebrate you
know like when you're able to like hit
that Homer in that big moment or like
just
whatever it is that you're helping your
team win you know how much work you have
put for it right so at least for that
moment you got to be able to celebrate
that and I I'm with you because you know
and
football
everybody knows how hard it is to score
a touchdown yeah so when those guys
score touchdowns they do all that right
well in baseball you know there is a
point where
even though I hit 30 home runs
think about how many times I hit you
know I've hit 600 times I've hit 30
homers so the time like yeah I want to
celebrate a little bit now I don't just
because
I was right on the tail end of the older
generation right but watching you guys
it actually is it's kind of inspiring
because it seems fun like doing doing
our Freddy dance right
like initially it was like you know kind
of
I don't know but then like how the
culture is going and how other cultures
are it's like it's fun you've been to
Dominican uh baseball games
tell me about that like tell tell tell
me and and some of the people the people
about that because that's a completely
different game than what it is in the
big leagues
that's what I grew up watching that was
like my business before I knew the
babies to say it like that so
um the games were there was fun you know
you play you play a short amount of Game
Boy every single game smarter and
everybody knows how hard it is to come
on top on that lead so like every single
hour every single Striker every single
home run all the stuff those people like
they celebrate the life your life or bad
thing you know like we are from
Dominican Republic we all have like the
station in the country that oh you're
rooting for this team and everybody kind
of bashing each other so like they go to
life to death on it so that's why like
they celebrate it so much they bring
bands to the field they the whole like
rivalry between I guess only saying like
all those older teams they just it's
unbelievable the energy I feel like if I
recommend you something just go watch it
go go one time yeah to the Dominican
Republic and just watch the game do you
feel like
the MLB could take some of those things
maybe not all of it but some of the the
the fun and Implement that we should do
that I think we should I think we should
I feel like it gives it gives the fans
and other things to go through the
ballpark and enjoy you know it gives it
gives something else like that is also
bringing your energy not us not just to
defense but also to the players and like
you cannot allow them to be who they are
yeah because of the personalities yeah
because at the end of the day like if I
step on the field and like I just go out
there and be myself I don't want to rub
somebody else the wrong way I'm just
like playing as free as I can play you
know it's not about the guy that I get
home with oh it's not allowed him
striking me out it's about him you know
it's about what he likes to do what he
wants to do I feel that's what it is
yeah I feel like everybody should be
allowed to do
to be themselves 100 right right because
at the end of the day we're all
different you come from a different
place that I did you grew up watching
something different that I did so like
why either you the why do I have to tell
you how to act right or you tell me how
do I well you don't when you never see
things through my eyes and that's I
understand that because
when I think when guys bat flip or
somebody strikes someone out to your
point it's not about that I struck you
oh it's more of I was successful in that
situation and this is my celebration
yeah that's what I think and like
whenever somebody strike me out if you
want to be pumped it's okay like that's
good that's I know what it feels like
you can do that I'm not gonna tell you
because I know I'm gonna I'm getting
fired up to come back and like try to
get you home now I want to celebrate too
right but it's not like about you
striking me out like me hitting on wrong
for you I want to be successful in that
it's just the moment it's just a moment
you know you gotta you want to
appreciate your moment in your own way
right and and I think like you said
maybe we should come up because like
jazz doing the the Euro Step Right or
yeah or or uh Ozuna when he took a
picture down you know um down the third
base you saw that in the VR oh see there
you go yeah you know tatis when he does
a little Shuffle thing around third base
right I think that does show personality
and that's like the signature you know
Immortal in the video games Mortal
Kombat you ever play Mortal Kombat of
course okay so you to finish it you know
the Baytown it's like you know you know
who you're picking you know the
finishing move right and so maybe that's
kind of what how we should view it like
Castillo's when he that's like his
that's his that's like his finishing
move right so maybe you know that's a
that's a good idea man that's a great
perspective I'm uh I'm trying to come up
with a signature or something I don't
know what it's going to be yeah we'll
see all right so take me back to Young
Julio man so you guys you were yeah take
me back to young young Julio growing up
in the Dr how was it and how tough was
it
because coming out of the Dr there's
it's a lot of people that play baseball
and the academies that are there there's
a lot of people and so you really have
to find figure out how to become better
than everyone so tell me about how the
experience was oh I mean I started
playing baseball in my hometown
um what was what like five six even
younger than that problem with my dad
but I started playing there until I was
like 14 that's whenever
um over there honestly I used to play on
the streets I used to play on the
baseball field after practice with
tennis ball with like bottles little
calves like with every single thing that
we could like think of we would be
playing baseball and like on the streets
everywhere pretty much everywhere at
school everywhere so baseball is
everyone the Dominican Republic and I
feel like that's also why the
competition is kind of hard because
everybody wants to be a baseball player
you know every every single kid their
dream and the best way out sometimes you
just be a baseball player that was the
case for me like it was a whole bunch of
other kids so when I was 14 that was
whenever this the this Academy is called
me and the academy name is called
Michelob and Mullis I trained there with
Kiko Pena and like his son and all that
um I was there for like a couple years
so that was when I was 14. I was there
for like a couple years doing tryouts
going to different parts of the
Dominican Republic doing tryouts
showcase like show you did a lot of
showcases yeah okay I do a lot of
tryouts when I was one was skit but that
was like the that was like kind of the
process of it yeah you needed to wait
until you were 16 to be able to sign
with a team man that's where the
Mariners came in okay when I was 16 so
from like 14 to like 16 I did a lot of
tryouts a lot of different teams a lot
of different teams had the opportunity
to do uh to sign you everything like
that but the best choice for me was the
Mariners back then I don't know I don't
know why but I just kind of felt that
connection with them I just felt like it
was like the best Organization for me to
to see in a way that they wouldn't they
would they were going to provide me with
the things I needed to get better okay
and that's what I saw in them and
we're here we're here now okay so you
sign 16 years old came over
and you tell me about your minor league
experience uh the minor league was
pretty cool honestly I got to was it a
different so you were was it different
like you were like wow I'm in the U.S
and this is completely different or
because
especially in the lower minor leagues a
lot of guys come over
and so were you comfortable I feel like
in a way when I was 14 I had to move
from my hometown to a different to a
city in Santiago okay so again I had to
leave my parents I leave my hometown so
that's when my process of like kind of
living the way it started oh okay so you
were kind of normal it was kind of
normal for you in a way yeah in a way
we're just I remember talking to my
parents when I was a kid and I was like
okay if I'm gonna do this like then be
crying and complaining I was like 14
maybe 15. and I was like if I'm gonna do
this I can't be crying complaining and
so and you came over you're already kind
of used to being on your own yeah and
you going through the minor leagues was
the minor League's tough for you uh it
was it was it was tough
in a way where I feel like at the same
time I kind of prepare myself a little
bit for it especially with the English
because my parents they when I went to
Santiago my parents uh
they didn't want me to rely really on
people like they wanted me to be my own
but my own personal not having to like
rely on somebody or like I needed to get
food if I needed to do this and that
they didn't want me to have that thing
in the middle so well I was like 14 15
they put me on the this institute to
kind of learn a little bit of English so
that's kind of like prepare myself for
learning before you came yeah years
before you came uh kind of yeah it's not
like I knew like how to speak English
fluently or like things like that but I
knew the basics I knew how to like put
together a sentence and like kind of
like say it like however I could but so
how did your English get so good just
just practices being here it was more so
I signed with the Mariners at 16 and I
remember that year they had like this
instructionally and they said they said
like six seven like Americans to the
academy in the Dominican Republic and
man I told him like Hey I don't know my
English is not good like I'm gonna tell
you from now but if
somehow you can help me out like I'm
gonna take it you know and it's okay if
you tell me hey it's not good like you
can say like this but the other day it's
gonna make me better at the other day we
were able to talk here now yeah because
like things like that so I just I feel
like props to them that they can like
help me out too to to be here well I
mean at least you and you cared about
learning learning about English so as
you were going rising up through the
miners
how was
how was having success because as you
you debuted 20 21 and so that means you
flew through the minor leagues and
sometimes having success like that is
hard because you you become you think
that it's all the time you think this is
how baseball really is so how was it
handling that Success Through the minor
leagues I mean honestly just kind of
like staying committed to where I wanted
to be you know I wanted to be in the
beliefs I wanted to get here so so you
didn't care about it didn't matter no
for me it didn't really care like I feel
like I I was doing what I needed to do
to get to the business as fast as I can
that I got here to help the team man I
remember I started like DSL but my whole
point wasn't like being good here in DSL
or like being good and loyal or being
good in high a or double leg it was how
can I learn everything I need to do to
get to the Middle East okay so if it was
this level I'd like what can I learn
here in this level if it wasn't the
other level walking alone here because
my end goal was always to be here right
and that's why I feel like I was viewing
as a preparation to get there nice just
being good at that level so I feel like
that's kind of how I handle like I
handle it being the minor lease it's
kind of like preparing myself to get out
there over here was your Dad or Mom or
were they one of your coaches growing up
or did they
I'm sure they helped you a lot but how
what was their relationship and with you
through all this because you
left not that you left but you kind of
had to leave a little bit at 14 and so
they were they were kind of
in the background watching while they're
you're 14 years old and you know now
obviously made to the bigley so how how
were they throughout this whole problem
I mean there were definitely I was
involved you know that where I was like
especially my dad like who was I was
involved into me doing the right thing
she was always calling me taking a knee
on me and like he was always he would
call it Santiago my mama too like they
would come to Santiago the city that I
was at to make sure that all the things
were going well and and you know I mean
you you're repairing now and like you
know how hard it would be to be away
from your kids so I feel like that was a
really hard process to them but at the
same time they were all in this together
you know like
if we started like crying complaining
about like oh we're so far away we're
gonna like I'll get side we're all gonna
be like make it I see all the hard Parts
but if we were instead of like that
we're focus on the things that we're
going to do together and then we
celebrate and joy and like all these
Hard Times we're just part of the
process you know so I feel like they
will always support me that while I was
there for me for whatever I need to do
as a parent as a friend
um I was like giving me that good advice
you know like we need it because you
know you go through 12 times you know
you go through 12 times and be able to
have them there was definitely like key
for for all this to happen you have any
brothers or sisters I do have an older
sister two yoga Simmons little boy a
little girl so do you feel like your
older sister did she help you with with
anything like just having someone else
to talk to I mean yeah definitely I feel
like me and my sister like well we
always have been pretty close and we
always are able to talk like anything
you know she was older than me but like
she was kind of like my little mom in a
way too because she always will take
care of me uh that's what I feel like
we're really close and talk about
anything with her so you have so own
sister two younger siblings yourself so
four and your mom and dad so when you
got the call
did you call all them I called my mom
and my dad okay so tell me about it you
got the call and what did you do first
oh man I I remember when Scott was
telling me that I was gonna go to the
biggest man I was blacked out like I I
didn't I was like blacked out I was just
like zeroing on his face and I was just
like listening to like man like why are
you gonna tell me I'm either gonna go
down to leave a double layer AAA are
going to go out to the buildings I knew
I did everything I could to like make
the team it was like right here right
now the Momo of my dreams am I other
gonna go there or not and like once and
once he told me that I was going to be a
big Leaguer like I you know I my hands
were sweating I was shaking you know you
get all those feelings it's like man
like basically finally yeah we were able
to get the opportunity to be here so
um tell me about your call with your
parents uh I called my dad my dad didn't
take the phone first yeah
so I was like okay whatever I guess he's
too busy right now but now I call my mom
and uh there was there was been videos
saying I'll die from it because my man
here they did a great job on that but
uh my mom was definitely really excited
you know like did she cry she was crying
yeah sure yeah my mom was definitely
crying from both but
it was definitely like I could tell like
how happy she was for me how proud of
that like everything the other sacrifice
that we have done and like man we come
from nothing basically so being able to
like do that step all of us as a family
together it was it was pretty cool and
so did you cry
I didn't cry man I don't know but I was
a little tearing up but that's okay
that's okay that's good I mean like you
said it's everything everything you
dreamed dreamed for you know everything
you worked hard for so it's okay so
and let me ask you one more thing before
we
move to the next uh subject
do you feel like
you know being that you know you
you have a big responsibility with this
team like do you feel like
it a lot
of pressure pressure is maybe the wrong
word but
I'm just gonna have to use it you have a
lot of pressure especially going down
this this last two weeks
to perform in order to help your team
get because y'all are right you're right
there yeah and you're you're gonna need
the guys to pitch well you're gonna need
you to play well
but knowing that you're you and like you
know this is the j-rod show here in
Seattle like do you feel like there's a
lot of pressure on you I mean and it's
good pressure like not bad pressure but
like good pressure pressure that you
enjoy like dude I feel like I definitely
enjoy that part because it's a
competition you know you're competing to
like get there and I feel like I enjoy
that part you know I enjoy to be able to
because I demand that for myself too you
know I wanna I wanna do good for the
team I want to be able to like perform
and we know what thing goes every single
time at the end of the year but
man I feel like in the way that I put it
it just I feel like we all gotta just
prepare you know we gotta be ready for
it like once we step on the field it's
like what can we do to just win you know
so I don't I don't I don't know I try to
simplify all the time just to kind of
prepare and like once as I step on the
field is
God guys the only one that knows it's
gonna happen but I want to be prepared
for whatever it needs to happen right
there and so when you when you go to
prepare and you know and like
every game matters right and not that
every game doesn't matter early in the
season but now every game matters like
does your preparation
change or does it do you add more do you
take a little more what what is it what
I feel like if I were to add one one
more thing is meditation
to say like that that's that's probably
like one thing that I would say helped
me to kind of like focus on the things
that I need to do now on the things that
are like kind of like a waste of time
like things that are not gonna have body
to where I need to go so I feel like I
like to meditate every single time like
that I I'm going to like to things that
are really like important like these
times not like this last stretch I like
to just focus your mind the things that
I need to do so during the day yo after
BP I'm assuming you meditate right
before the game yeah do you go you go in
a room by yourself or do you put your
headphones in you sit at your locker
what does that look like if I'm at home
I'll go into like a room this this room
that we got that it's kind of like the
Sleep room nap room okay yeah so I go in
there and I always like take my take my
time or whatever how long do you need
um the straw the store all I do is like
10 five minutes but literally sometimes
I go in there for like 30. oh so you're
taking a nap that you're not meditating
well I do meditate for the first bottle
you meditate until you fall asleep yeah
okay okay yeah it helps you and so
do you you feel like
that meditation is kind of what
allows your brain to to
have all the thoughts that run through
you let them go through no matter what
they are like is that what you use the
meditation for yeah definitely you know
you always gotta prepare you go to the
gym you go to do your healing routine
you do all those things but I feel like
that I should say like that's kind of
like organizes everything you know like
it puts everything where it needs to go
and it just allows me to just go out
there to the few and just play free so
you so based off you meditating that
means you're you're bit really big on in
mental health yeah and so how often do
you practice or
or whatever like mental health like so
what that looks like for me is
when I'm at home or or you know even in
the box or on the field wherever I'm at
uh instead of telling us telling myself
like
um
don't look for this pitch or I don't
want to do this or I don't want to get
beat deep or I don't want to
I don't want to eat this food instead of
saying what I don't want to do I try and
practice what I actually do want to do
right and so how does that work for you
like how do you put that into your life
how do you implement these things into
your life I feel like I always I feel
like meditating and like other things of
mental health mental health is more
about realizing like you said like
realizing all those thoughts and then
like you said too it's just like kind of
putting the energy and the things that
you really want to do like you said like
I feel like that's that's really big key
for it and I feel like that I do a lot a
lot of those things because that's what
you see that's what whenever you're like
doing some meditation how they tell you
instead of like you think you know the
negative things just kind of put that
energy in the positive way and like in
the way that you talk to yourself yeah
because especially self-talk yeah
self-talk it's just like in the way that
you talk to yourself and how do you
manifest all those things because if you
start thinking about the negative or
you're putting negative things out there
yeah if you start like thinking about
how do you talk positive to yourself and
like just kind of like spread that
positivity throughout like not just you
for the people around you how you talk
like how you like giving that bias and
things like that so I feel like that's
what I try to do that's what I pay
attention to yeah exactly okay so this
is something super random I forgot to
ask you earlier
you know you signed your deal you're
going to be a a mariner for
a while
would you do when you uh when you would
you get when you first signed what was
your first purchase for me for me I
bought my GUI you bought a g wag yeah
that's that was my first fully loaded
custom everything uh
yeah you could say like that was brand
new though too brand new G-Wagon and why
I G wagon Oh I thought that was that was
gonna warm my dream cars hours and I
don't know I like sporty cards but I
feel like that's not like such a sporty
car but just kind of like a strong like
nice protected car that I always liked
and yeah that was my first purchase for
myself and do you and obviously you're a
jewelry guy you like nice nice pieces I
really like your j-rod necklace right
there that looks really good
you like watches too uh yeah well I
haven't gotten into it like that like
that
are you planning on getting into in the
watches definitely and and do you do you
actually use your watch when you have a
watch do you actually use it for the
time or you just got it no I just got it
yeah so your your watches don't they
don't even work
this one's not working right now this
one is actually awarded it working okay
oh oh I don't know if you saw this but
Deion Sanders coach Prime at Colorado
yeah do you do you know much about Deion
Sanders at all coach Prime I mean I
definitely know his phrase I look good
look good feel good okay so that's
that's him in a nutshell
he um
there was a coach that told him
or not even told him that you saw him
you know what I'm talking about how do
you feel about that like wearing are you
on base or all base with glasses during
the interview
we're here right now on base yeah it's
not it's not I feel like like we were
talking earlier everybody got their own
personality you know that was his
household was taught that he doesn't
know what in the Sanders household was
taught like he doesn't know under that
he doesn't know that the value that he
was raised with you know he'd see the he
sees the glasses and the hat and all
that but what is he about yeah do you
got the time to talk to him like I
actually learn about him so I feel like
I'm on base on that you know you're
doing you he has to be him I mean the
man said
he's packing up all his luggage
and he's bringing oh he's bringing a lot
of luggage but it's all Louie so if he
says that you know he got to wear
glasses in interviews right so I mean
again coach Prime just uh being himself
and I think he's like pretty much the
number one person everybody could look
at yeah who said who always is himself
but handles his business as well and
there is space for both you know okay so
let me ask this because this has been a
huge topic
on this show
anime
you watch anime definitely
okay
when did you first start watching anime
well I was a kid like back in the
Dominican Republic like I feel like I'm
throughout my whole life I've always
watched Adam
and
do you watch regular TV as well uh not
very much so you watch more anime than
regular TV definitely yeah
does animate they make movies they do
they do make movies too but like it's
like more like uh animated movies like
that okay so give me give me give me
what's your favorite anime my favorite
anime is Naruto Naruto yeah that's my
favorite all the time and and have you
watched all the episodes of that yeah
everything they come out with this
second part it's called boruto but it's
kind of like his son I didn't really get
much into that one because you know like
you you like your character you kind of
want to see him but yeah I watch pretty
much every single one of them okay so
I got this game
called Blind rankings blind rankings and
it's about animes oh my God okay so I'ma
tell you I'mma say anime
and you can't it you can own you can
only rank it once right so you don't
know all the five I'm gonna say okay
let's see
Dragon Ball Z
two
Dragon Ball Z number two that was a
quick two too okay it's great too Dragon
Ball Z is number two let's go with
one piece I I'm a lot of people might
say a lot of things about this but I
didn't really get into one piece okay
because I feel like one piece is all his
own chains say like that like
um and if you didn't start like and I
grew up with it there are so many
episodes okay so I feel like I didn't
really get into it because I was a
little late to the party okay and it was
a lot of episodes so I was like
nah I'm gonna put it I'm gonna put it on
five because I don't know I know a lot
of people like it and I respect every
single one of you guys
you ain't got to explain none of them I
didn't I didn't watch I didn't watch it
so it's fifth it's going fifth yeah all
right what about bleach bleach fourth
didn't watch it you didn't watch Bleach
either okay
Demon Slayer they must Slayer I'm gonna
put it ah you guys just fire that in me
yeah there's five animals okay I'm gonna
put them on Slayer three
Demon Slayer three and
Naruto that's messy there yeah that's
the top three I definitely watch uh demo
Slayer is really good anime they suck
off a little bit in the last last season
I gotta say that but Dragon Ball Z right
now it's all my top my top two Dragon
Ball Z was the one that basically every
single time after school I would
literally just run back to making them
time because they always just play one
episode yeah for like 30 minutes I
didn't want I wanted to make it on time
for that did you ever like draw the
characters ah not really I'm I'm getting
into dry a little bit but oh you're
getting in the drawing yeah I'm I'm
trying I'm trying to learn trying to
learn so if anybody got advice for me
send it this way okay all right so I got
some um
got some fan questions before we wrap
all right so first question is
people are split on sunglasses During
adult conversations that's not a
question this is a statement
someone is riding with us when it comes
to glasses I
I on on set you know on on during
interviews whatever I don't understand
why people care so much about
someone else wearing sunglasses because
to me it's like it ain't affecting your
day no it ain't got nothing to do with
your day nothing you at work or wherever
you are
and you turn a judge over here you know
what I'm saying and I'm you know I'm
just over here vibing with Julio we got
glasses on and now we gotta take them
off so anyways next question
what's your dream home run derby matchup
my dream home run derby Macho it can be
they can be from the past or now ah only
I feel like I really wanna watch
Giancarlo George
uh
who else
bloody for sure
uh senior no I don't know July again
okay I don't know why
uh it was a big going on Derby guy
they had a really big going on Derby
it's George Hamilton
oh yeah yeah he got uh people didn't
know about that he had a crazy Home Run
Derby
um so you got vladi Jr
you said yeah bloody George judge stanza
Josh Hamilton one more
bonds Barry Bonds I want to just see
that guy swinging
yeah I would love to see him in person
imagine just to see like no man that's
crazy I got another question uh would
you rather spend a spend a year on Mars
by yourself
or party on a island with your friends
with my friends
you couldn't do it by yourself no I
don't think I could do it by my by
myself either
um imagine something weird is coming out
of there yeah and Mars like where we
come with that what am I going to do
okay access going to Mars with my
friends maybe you know
I'm going on the island no matter what I
got one more question last question last
last question would you rather hit a
walk-off home run
to win the WBC or make the uh make the
catch to win the World Series wow like
make like a we'll we'll say rob a homer
to win a World Series Robert Homer to
win a World Series are here to walk off
Homer to win the WBC
wow man that's such a hard question
can we do both
uh I think it has yeah it has ore in
there so you got to choose one ah yeah
man
that's so hard for those who are
watching this that's how much the WBC
like matters to us yeah and that's how
it makes us feel yeah like it it means
this much that he has a hard time
answering this question but you got to
answer it though ain't no way oh my God
man that's hard can we live that for the
next episode
um
let's see it's just one or the other I
mean
man
I love the Mariners fans but I want to
do it for their country man
[Music]
for the Dr Julio
wow hey that's that's that
that's real though I'm glad you were
honest I'm glad you're honest about that
because you know
I'm not Dominican so I I'm sure
I can only imagine being demanding life
over there that's what I'm saying I can
only imagine being Dominican and putting
on that that uniform and then playing in
the wvc like it's a tiny country man
yeah a little country and be able to
represent that and just put on your
chest man
you guys know I love them but
I gotta do it for the walk-up and it's a
walk-off Homer too
he's old
all right man Julio thanks for coming on
here
um obviously I've been watching the last
couple years
um it's been fun uh
fun watching not only you
playing but mostly you just becoming who
you are and I think you have a big
personality and I think you embrace it
and I think that's super important super
important for not just you but for our
game for your teammates I'm sure that
goes a long way for for your teammates
you being the leader you're doing
everything uh you need to do embracing
the pressure embracing this pressure
that you do need to play well for you
guys to make it you know and and
obviously everyone has to play well this
is not just on you everyone has to play
with everyone has a pitch well play
defense with all this other stuff
but a lot is kind of right on you and I
think
talking to you now you really Embrace
that and it's good to it's good to it's
good to know that
young guys especially you're only 22
years old you uh are very mature and you
have a long successful career brother so
um again uh we'll see how this this
battle goes this weekend don't play too
well it'll be it'll be fun though it'll
be fun
guys thanks for joining
um if there is anywhere out there that
does drawing lessons paying lessons
whatever it is please please find Julio
and uh we will be catching you guys on
the next episode of on base see you guys
later
foreign
[Music]